and columnist for National Public Radio
next he discusses the state of America's
libraries with American Library
Association president John Gorman this
talk from the Ala s annual midwinter
meeting in San Antonio Texas is about an
hour 15 minutes we are extremely
fortunate to have with us today a most
distinguished keynote speaker noted
author Andre Codrescu
Andre is a weekly commentator for
National Public Radio's all things
considered and outspoken and inventive
novelist essayist filmmaker and poet he
founded net it's the literary journal
exquisite corpse
Andres made appearances on The Today
Show The Tonight Show the David
Letterman Show and Charlie Rose his
commentary and book reviews have been
published in The New York Times The
Boston Globe the Philadelphia Inquirer
the Chicago Tribune and Newsday among
others his travel film Rhodes scholar
won a Peabody Award his best-selling
novels include the blood countess and
Messiah
Andre teaches English at Louisiana State
University in Baton Rouge Louisiana his
latest book new orleans mon amour was
published on January the 6th 2006
subtitled 20 years of writings from the
city the book is a collection of essays
sketching portraits of the city and its
inhabitants Publishers Weekly says
quotes readers cannot help coming away
from reading it without abiding hope in
the ability of ordinary people under the
worst circumstances to rising to
whatever challenges they face
immediately after this program mr.
Codrescu will be signing copies of the
book in the foyer of this theater
through the generosity of his publishers
Algonquin Books the book which normally
sells for fourteen
dollars will be available to you for $10
before I invite Andre to the podium I'd
like to call your attention to the index
cards that were distributed at the door
the cards will be used for a question or
answer session at the end of the program
if you did not get a card at the door
and would like one please raise your
hand we'll collect the cards toward the
end of the program and now please join
me in welcoming our speaker Andre code
rescue
[Music]
thank you Michael and before I get to my
remarks I would like to add just a
little bit to what my fellow Louisianan
told you which is that I would hope as
wellis has both speakers that you are
going to be in New Orleans in June I'm
going to quote two paragraphs from a
letter I received to two days before I
came here from Ronald B Ava who is fund
development counsel for the New Orleans
Public Library's he says and you know it
bears repeating Hurricane Katrina hit
the New Orleans Public Library severely
all of its 13 buildings are damaged
eight of them are ruined books furniture
computers all beyond saving
80% of the employees laid off we are
working hard to recover and he writes
the letter to make sure that three three
points get across one ally members
please do come to the LA conference in
New Orleans don't change your plants the
city is recovering and we'll be ready
for your conference and it's it's true
in fact many New Orleanians are well
aware that ala did not pull out and they
are grateful and enthusiastic about your
visit and the city is coming back and
it's not there is no danger there in
fact if anything there's less danger
so the criminals have left they've gone
to other places or they can practice
their craft like Houston New Orleans
public library of course that may not
please some of you who like that edge of
danger to the city but New Orleans
Public Library will was hit very hard by
Katrina and is recovering slowly as you
heard the Orleans Public Library needs
your help in Moore to rebuild please
help talk to the New Orleans Public
Library staff at their booth on the
exhibit floor to learn more about the
rebuilding campaign and how you can
helps I have done my duty now I am going
to mention again this city and in the
storm in another
context I was hoping to answer your
inquiry into some of the theme of your
conference and thank you again for the
opportunity and pleasure to address
librarians some of my favorite people my
books are full of librarians I feel that
you and along with publishers and
writers are keeping the flame of
literacy flickering in this pixelate at
times not an easy thing to do I could
write a whole book about librarians I
probably have should be like George
Simon on who had the secretary who who
knew all his books and so when seminar
had some idea for another book he would
ask did I write that one and I said yes
you did in 1947 but I did write there
are librarians in several of my novels
in Casanova in Bohemia by the novel just
before my most recent Casanova himself
an old man is a librarian at the library
of ducks now duchcov in that in the
Czech Republic which is what he spent
the last years of his life so the book
takes place almost entirely in the
library and then in my most recent novel
Wakefield's the daughter of the main
character Wakefield is a librarian so
it's a great affection that I I stand
here and I also hate repeating myself
this is why I'm not an actor so I'll try
and say a few things that may resonate
at your current concerns and there are
three questions that I put to myself in
the hope of thinking about the future of
libraries and librarians and these
questions are one how is the librarian
better than the mouse o'clock - what can
library buildings do besides holding
books and three what does the freedom to
read mean to the American Library
Association - the first question how is
the library better that a mouse-click
the answer is not much and at the same
time much more
Google will give you the information
they need a lot faster than without
having to go to the library so it's
unfair for a human being to compete with
the machine on this field because the
machine never gets tired and doesn't
waste time caring about the quality of
the information what's more what's more
what's more caring is not all that
necessary if it's just about pure and
expedient information I had a poet
friend Hans Volcker who loved the poet
Hart Crane and out of the sheer love he
produced the concordance of all the work
of Hart Crane in the days before
computers did this kind of thing and the
computer concordance which took about
twelve minutes came out at the same time
as honza's five-year long labor of love
hands found two mistakes in the computer
version that's what he's carrying at him
actually factually but in truth Hans
didn't do his concordance for factual
reasons he did it because he wanted to
feel the weight of the words themselves
how many times crane used them what that
meant to the poet what that means to
poetry in general to Hunter's poetry in
particular namely he counted for the
sake of poetry not for the sake of
numbers to anyone wanting to know just
how many times Hart Crane used the
conjunction with this sort of
distinction won't make a bit of
difference but who would want to know
and for what reason exactly how many
times Hart Crane is the conjunction with
out of a handful of people are hundred
at most and I'm speaking very
optimistically here including academics
who have actually read Hart cranes
poetry in its entirety a much smaller
number perhaps two people to speak very
optimistically now might actually care
how many times Hart Crane wrote with I
mean living people because Hans Volker
Hans Volker is no longer with us and out
of those two one of them would have to
be a linguist in the other an insane
person so we'll leave the linguist aside
for a while with his concordance in the
examine the
in person this insane person is is
familiar to all public library
librarians he or she uses the library as
a living room and is a command post for
descending and reception of cosmic
signals I'm sure that you have carried
on many discussions about the proper
ways to deal with homeless and mentally
ill people who think of their of
libraries as the churches why they don't
take refuge in churches instead of
libraries is a very good question
actually
perhaps the sensitive apparatus of the
mentally ill prefers secularism to
religion or maybe Church custodians
aren't dis kindest librarians who may be
more Christian than the declared sword
in any case the crazy who has received
the special message that the number of
width in cranes poetry are an
indispensable piece in the universal
puzzle should have your full attention
here is the only person who for reasons
not immediately understandable has
chosen to function outside the Machine
your public librarian must now be a poet
as well as a nurse in the social worker
three job descriptions that lie at least
in part outside the incoming rule of
Google whatever Google cannot provide
the librarian needs to namely a great
deal of humanity and poetic
understanding in addition to being a
poet a nurse in the social worker the
librarian of the future must have a
passion for esoteric literature such as
modern poetry in order to feel at home
in precisely those areas smaller and
smaller of the human psyche that lie
outside the machine which brings me to
question number two what can library
buildings do besides holding books the
Katrina tragedy is very instructive here
because public libraries are
indispensable to poor communities like
New Orleans because they service
cultural centers for people who still
have the integrity or not to surrender
to television and video games and
public library buildings are also useful
for sheltering a great number of people
and if anyone let's say in the past in
our government or in whoever built those
libraries would have given thought to
public libraries in New Orleans they
might have built them safe enough to not
be destroyed or even to serve as
shelters in the disaster the storm that
ripped the roof right off the scandalous
poverty in our city also exposed the
shabby treatment of programs intended to
better community life the the lack of
foresight and imagination by the
bureaucrats in charge of public monies
is beyond appalling it's criminal
libraries may not be the first priority
in a city beset by thousands of personal
tragedies and hundreds of major and
urgent needs but they are an
irreplaceable piece of the complex
puzzle of urban civilization take away
the library and what you have is a
mindless shopping mall
existing and future libraries built
buildings have to become cultural
centers that emphasize those aspects of
humanity that lie outside the machine I
know many libraries do this now I mean
that there are children's readings and
poetry readings and lectures and
discussions and exhibits and all sorts
of things but there is you know in some
of the existing in many of the existing
libraries the bookshelves get in the way
of some of these things there is a bit
of inbuilt inhibition that can put a
damper on the thing like a poetry
reading which sometimes results in wine
spillage the libraries of the future
should pay particular attention to the
coming library without books just like
the museum without art the j paul Getty
Museum in Los Angeles for instance
emphasized the architecture over the
somewhat dated function of the building
in the library of the future the library
without books there should be
dormitories and socializing rooms for
those fewer and fewer souls who haven't
been captured by Google in addition
poetry readings and lectures should
occur in classrooms that give an
unimpeded view of green spaces outside
for dreaming the poet or the lecturer
should be the only one of the only one
of the possible focus points of the room
I'm giving them now full vent to my
sci-fi urges the library of the future
should also be mobile made of inflatable
materials that can be carried from
neighborhood to make neighborhood or to
remote areas in other words the
bookmobile should be expanded to
accommodate crowds and to be as big in
this architectural II interesting as
possible here I had the vision of
low-flying Hindenburg's the turret
accessible by elevators just like a sort
of 19th century science fiction ideas of
what the 20th and the 21st century would
look like the events produced in the
bookmobile library without books of the
future should not be limited to events
tied into preexisting books they should
encourage writing and encourage also the
kind of events that inspired
writers such as circuses and music
you're ready for circuses also hours
should be set aside so that the mentally
ill renamed Sears have regular
consultation hours so they can enlighten
people about the significance of such
things as the conjunction with in the
heart cranes poetry in short librarians
need to feed Google brand new
information instead of letting Google
turn them into Google ego furs and the
way to do that is to produce culture
through the buildings and the creation
in situ of reading materials technology
will make it possible to publish and
broadcast all that is produced in the
library so that instead of just being
repositories of information libraries
could be active participants in culture
this is the only way to beat Google to
bequeath to it the repository and
guiding functions that libraries used to
have and to producers of culture
so well librarians will need to reinvent
themselves along with libraries well why
not you know who would invent ourselves
all the time
there is a certain power that librarians
have in our society which come from this
association here the American Library
Association which is a real force in
American life through its well-read
membership membership and the positions
that you take on social issues I was
born in a place where people are
forbidden to read most of what we
consider the fundamental books of
Western civilization not only were we
forbidden to read authors like James
Joyce for instance but to be found in
possession of George Orwell's 1984 could
land one in prison for years my good
luck was to meet dr. Martin in my
adolescence in my home town dr. Martin
was a retired professor who had
collected and kept in his modest
apartment the best of the interwar
Romanian writers and he had all the
poets who had been blacklisted by the
Communist authorities he had Luciano
Agha Aaron coat Rouge Tristan Tzara
Gerasim Lucca these are all names to us
that we we had no access to whose works
we had no access he owned the complete
works of in Romanian and in French of
the religious comparative Mucha le a day
in the philosopher Emil Cioran
and among his treasures or translations
of Sigmund Freud and Robert Maceo and
George Orwell in Paul Claudel and in the
Stalinist period which did not end in
Romania until 1964 and then only briefly
any of the books in dr. Martens library
could have earned him years of hard
labor in addition to owning them
he lent them to us young high school
writers who absorbed them thirstily and
read them because we knew what the risks
are all their friends and ourselves were
taking I became a writer because I read
forbidden books books forbidden by an
authoritarian government are the only
reason I am now standing before you so
for more than three and a half decades
that I spent in the United States I've
taken my right to read and freedom of X
and very seriously I've seen many
attempts on it most recently by section
215 of the Patriot Act which has raised
a good reason the ire of librarians the
al I fight for the freedom to read
against censorship in the Patriot Act
has been of your most significant
accomplishments another has been the
promotion of human rights and
intellectual freedom worldwide I'm going
to quote you to yourselves that quote
from the ala policy manual quote freedom
of expression is an inalienable human
right necessary to self-government vital
to resistance to oppression crucial to
the cause of justice and further that
the principles of freedom of expression
should be applied to libraries and
librarians all over the world given this
crystal-clear position it was it a great
deal of dismay that I learned that the
American Library Association has taken
no action to condemn the imprisonment of
librarians the banning of books the
repression of expression and the torture
of dissidents only 90 miles from our
shores in Cuba in March 1988 two
residents of Las Tunas Rahman Collison
burtom a healer opened the private
library in their home dedicated to
offering Cubans books not officially
available the fellows Varela library was
the first of a network of public private
libraries that were established by
volunteers in Cuba to bring lights to
the oppressiveness of the Castro regime
a hundred and three libraries and a
hundred and eighty thousand registered
patrons are affiliated with the
expanding libraries independent
libraries project by the end of 2002
from the very beginning of their
existence the private librarians were
threatened or subject to threats
harassment evictions arrests police
raids and the seizure of book
collections books that disappeared so
quickly they could have only been burned
in November 1999 Rahman colas was
arrested Amnesty International declared
him a prisoner of conscience hundreds of
other librarians are arrested not long
afterward in the libraries and
collections confiscated the ala s
international rights committee looked
rather late
into the dire situation of the Cuban
librarians on January 13 2001 the
latin-american subcommittee of the IRS
seek conducted the hearing at the ala
midwinter conference in Washington were
reports on the worsening situation in
Cuba were presented by witnesses using
accounts from Human Rights Watch report
reporters on frontier Amnesty
International as well as Press reports
from The Washington Post and The
Associated Press
people like vaclav havel the hero of the
Velvet Revolution that brought down the
vicious regime regime in Czechoslovakia
Lacroix Lanza winner of the Nobel Peace
Prize and former President of Poland in
our Podgorny
former President of Hungary joined to
condemned Castro's imprison Makoti
imprisonment of Cubans for merely for
daring to express an opinion other than
the official one even well-known leftist
dissidents such as Nam Chomsky with whom
I personally disagree on a lot of issues
actually historian Howard Zinn in
philosopher Cornel West have condemned
the arrest of librarians in Cuba and
quote the shockingly long prison
sentences imposed after unfair trials
unquote amazingly enough the final
report of the ala in 2001 declined to
recognize the new Cuban libraries as
libraries and the librarians dim salsa
refer to quote as individuals associated
with these collections on code since
then those individuals have been subject
to brutal imprisonment and the books
have disappeared the ala counselors have
remained silent on the issue to this day
so am i hallucinating here is this the
same American Library Association that
stands against censorship and for
freedom of expression everywhere there
are some people like the Civil Liberties
columnist Nat Hentoff and Robert Kent
founder of friends of Cuban libraries
who have accused the LA leadership of a
cover-up
this organization cannot logically act
against provision 215 of the Patriot Act
and a proof of Fidel Castro's order 88
which denies all the rights we cherish I
went to Cuba 1967 I'm sorry
1997 I left to Romania 1967
but I went to Cuba 1997 which was just
before the papal visit that year and I
was appalled by the lack of books I was
reminded of my poor sad Romania and the
1960s dismal prison were food for body
and mind or nearly in existence Cubans
are literally starving physically and
intellectually looking to the sultry
pages of the Communist Party's official
paper grandma reminded me also of the
pathetic simulacra of writing that
stained the pages of Romania's official
papers during the years of the
dictatorship there are nothing but
production reports interviews with el
maximum leader lies about the bright
future and not a shred of truth about
the actual conditions of people lived in
in Romania after 1989 Romanians were
able to read with astonishment just how
horrific things had been for them just
how much they've been lied to in just
how much they had missed the avidly
consumed books like George Orwell's 1984
Cuba today is the Romania of my growing
up and I only hope for the sake of the
Cubans that the hundred thousand dr.
Martens are ready to rise to take the
place of those who have been arrested
and tortured by the given regime I also
hope that in keeping with its tradition
in charter of defending the freedom to
read in freedom of expression the
American Library Association will pass a
resolution condemning Castro's regime
for flagrant violations of basic human
rights
to not do so itself defeating an early
wife saw the credibility that we might
have in fighting the much milder
provisions of the Patriot Act not to
speak of the fact it's much easier to
fight for freedom to read in a country
where every book is available well it is
much more difficult to make a meaningful
statement about the place where books
are an enemy of the state so this would
be my answers to the three questions
namely one how's the librarian better
than the mouse clerk - what can I like
what can library buildings do besides
holding books 3 what does the freedom
read the freedom to read mean - the Ala
but all three questions resolving - one
as far as we are concerned namely do we
believe that we can survive in the 21st
century and if so are we going to be
active and imaginative enough to make a
difference both to people who are
forgetting to read and to people who are
forbidden to read if we can we're in
business
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much Andre I am
incredibly impressed as usual by the
fluency and Wonder with which you use
the English language I'm equally
impressed by the skills of our
projectionists and I look forward to a
discussion with you after I've made a
few remarks I know very well why you're
here and it's not to listen to me
but I would just like to make a few
remarks on our profession and on
education for our profession as Andre
has told us and others tell us it is a
great thing to be a librarian and to
serve individuals communities and
society as a whole in what we do
Melville juhi the founding father of
American librarianship told us that we
are members of a profession 130 years
ago and few have doubted our
professionalism and expertise in the
years since you are indispensable to the
life of the mind to people old and young
and to the preservation of our
civilization this is a noble calling and
one that imposes duties and
responsibilities including the privilege
and duty of working with and preserving
the human record that vast assemblage of
texts images and symbols in all formats
that has come down to us from the dawn
of the age of writing the age when in
the words of Thomas Carlyle miracles
began that human record is important
because we have to recognize that there
are really only three ways in which
people learn they learn from experience
and they've been doing that ever since
they were human
they learned from people who are wiser
than they are who know more than they
are
rabbis shaman's teachers professors etc
and they've been doing that ever since
the first wise woman gathered a band of
Hurley humans together and told about
the history of that band and
incidentally one of the many irritating
things about fads in higher education
today is the way we're constantly being
told that teaching is not the thing
learning is the thing and that a teacher
will learn as much from the students as
they learn from her or him personally
given the cost of college tuition I
would not like to pay for someone to be
enrolled in a class with someone who
didn't know any more than they did so we
learned from experience and we learned
from people who know more than we do and
the only other way in which we learn is
some interaction with the human record
from reading from viewing from profiting
from the knowledge and the wisdom and
the information and the literature of
the ages the library archipelago is a
vast structure of interconnected subsets
of that human record and we're all
responsible for maintaining and
assisting in the use of that structure
our values service intellectual freedom
equitable access to library services
preservation of the human record the
promotion of literacy and learning
democracy rationalism and defense of the
privacy of library users are all
centered on the human record that record
made accessible because of the
connections that librarians have created
and that we use daily almost without
thought we're concerned with all aspects
of use of the human record
from a quick search for a piece of data
to the provision of research materials
for a future Nobel prize-winner from the
provision of life-saving information in
the hospital library to storytelling to
a group of rapt six-year-olds I knew
when I wrote that this is probably going
to show up as WR AP peds six year olds
[Music]
did it from databases of online
newspapers to irreplaceable collections
of medieval manuscripts our work with
the human record embraces and transcends
technology we welcome and have always
welcomed all forms of communication
technology and rejoice in their richness
and the ways in which each form
contributes to and enhances the mission
of libraries and librarians this is a
positive and affirming profession that
embraces change while maintaining our
enduring mission and our time-tested
values there are always new challenges
and always new ways to respond to those
challenges but it is as foolish to
reject the lessons of the past as it is
to try to turn the tide of change let us
take intellectual freedom as an example
as we all know that freedom insists that
men and women are entitled to think and
believe what they wish and that that
freedom is fatally compromised if those
men and women are restricted in their
access to the human record there have
been three main reasons for such
restrictions blasphemy indecency and
Sedition all attempts to impose
conformity and to suppress freedom of
thought in short to shut off access to
part of the human record based on the
religious political or moral beliefs of
others John Milton wrote in his area our
Pataca in 1644 the quotes well knows he
who uses to consider that our faith and
knowledge thrives by exercise as well as
our limbs and complexion truth is
compared in Scripture to a streaming
fountain if a waters flow not in
perpetual progression they second into a
muddy pool of conformity and tradition
Milton was prosecuted on the grounds of
both sedition and blasphemy but his
words are nonetheless true and injurer
long after the names of his would-be
census of forgotten we librarians are
mute in klore inglorious Milton's by
comparison but our struggles against the
iniquities of the USA PATRIOT Act arise
from that same opposition to muddy pools
of conformity from the belief that free
inquiry and free access to the human
record without the constrictions or
oversight of any arm of government are
essential to human progress and to the
freedom and democracy that our opponents
proclaim but do not honor
we have a duty to preserve and transmit
the values and practices of
librarianship as well as the human
record that is the basis for the work of
librarians and in that context I have
some questions to ask you about our
profession and our future I'm not even
good at when tempted sir these questions
at this session but I hope to begin to
do so in the months to come but in the
meantime I'd like you to ponder these
questions can we as a professional
association define the elements of our
profession in the 21st century so that
they can be understood and passed on to
future generations are we confident that
the present structure of library
education will ensure an adequate supply
of new librarians to carry out our
mission are we carrying out the duty of
a profession to control education for
our profession and to monitor the
programs that teach and do research into
our profession is ala sufficiently
assertive as our other professional
bodies such as the American Bar
Association and the American Medical
Association in ensuring that all the
programs that educate librarians are
carrying out their responsibilities to
the fall is it unreasonable for ala to
demand in return for the value of its
accreditation a curriculum that
comprehends all the components of
librarianship as defined by the American
Library Association the education of
future librarians is a central issue in
considering the future of our profession
the future of the human record and the
future of our civilization the stakes
are high and failure cannot be
contemplated
thank you
we will now change the format of this
program from formal presentation to
dialogue discussion and a question and
answer session if you have a card with a
question or comment please raise your
hand and a staff person in the aisle
will collect
I'll be broadcasting
we're broadcasting can we be heard Thank
You Andre
some comments I think the
misunderstanding that's arisen there are
people in Ala who have looked much more
deeply into this question than I but I
think the thank you I think the question
is not that a la has failed to condemn
suppression of literature suppression of
reading suppression of freedom and
inquiry anywhere in the world I think
the fact is that we have done so and I
can't cite you chapter and verse but I
am fairly certain that I remember the
council passing resolutions deploring
the activities in this area of the Cuban
government which I am here today to tell
you I think are reprehensible and in
which against they against everything I
stand for as opposed to getting involved
in a kind of political to and fro about
the status of people who claim to be
librarians and who are in many cases and
I'm not speaking now the people in
prison these people should not be in
prison they should be freed immediately
they should never have been sent and
sent to prison for the activities
connected with any kind of dissemination
of information or literature but we do
not want to get involved with the kind
of politics which grows up around the
Cuban exile community the Republican
Party the Cuba and the Cuban government
I think we've taken a principled stand
on many many occasions against
suppression of thought in all country
well it seems to me that it isn't a
matter of general principle because
clearly the the la stands for freedom to
read it is a case of specific a specific
Russian librarians and libraries is a
case of making a clear clear stand with
these people who have been imprisoned
for landing books for being librarians
well I don't see why they would because
so-called librarians include since
clearly there's no one to certify them
in anyway they gathered books in their
house and they gave them to people who
wanted to read them well I guess you
know there is a dispute as to whether
that activity is being a librarian but
the essential point is and my memory I
believe is correct on this when we had
the reports of the intellectual freedom
Committee and the International
Relations Committee that the ala council
condemned the imprisonment of these
people the fact is that but we are still
in prison right but we have been
mischaracterized well of course you know
they're still spying on your telephone
conversations where we condemn that the
the fact is that we have been
misrepresented by Nat Hentoff who I have
a great deal of respect for in other
fields and by other people and
particularly the gentleman you mentioned
mr. Kent who is perpective and
consistently misrepresented a LA's
position and I think there is some
dispute about the funding of the people
who claim to set up these libraries
whether there are life whether they are
libraries and librarians it does not
alter the fundamental fact that if I
have a collection of books in my house
and and I'd lend one of them to you but
I'm not of being a librarian in that
case I'm being a citizen and democracy
that that process should never be
impeded it should never be impeded in
kubera should have been beaten anywhere
well we believe in the access to books
and other reading matters anywhere in
the world well the man who lent us books
was a librarian there was our librarian
he was the not the official librarian
because official librarians didn't help
us he was somebody who
who did this because he loved books and
he he he he wanted us especially young
people to read them he would have been
arrested you live done a great deal of
time so yes we would have so I I think
that the American Library Association
should make a stronger point in
solidarity with with these disseminators
of books which in my mind the librarians
I don't know what else to call them well
either it depends how you define members
of a profession I mean we're talking
about Cuba where there is nothing to
reads I mean the Cuban government
forbids the publishing of literature the
Cuban ok Cubans have a Cuban writer set
in exile for the most part the real good
ones have you know scattered all over
and I decided there was another reason
for the absence of reading literature in
Cuba and it's the American embargo
nobody's for day you know the embargo
has been used by Fidel Castro's a good
excuse actually for keeping his people
oppressed and this there's no question
in my mind about this I was in Cuba and
spoke to to a good many Cuban
intellectuals who were against the
embargo and said lift the embargo and
see what happens Castro wouldn't lasts
another months and I wish they would so
divide could I maybe just ask you a
question one of these cards that in the
same area but slightly wider issue you
suggested that we passed a resolution
that a la passed a resolution condemning
Castro many librarians say that ala has
no business making such political
statements and should stick to the
library business there are battles
enough how would you respond to those
people
well the LA is already involved in all
kinds of politics I mean the the
business of the Patriot Act it certainly
resounds to the credit of the
organization and this is not a very
far-fetched leap
I think the point of it and it's not
condemning
is really condemning the policy of the
Cuban government in suppression of
freedom to read I think the point is
this person feels that we probably
shouldn't be passing anything on the
Patriot Act or or anything else that is
not directly and minutely focused on my
burn ship I'd just be interested in your
views on that well I think the American
Library Association is some of the most
articulate associations in in our
country it has consistently taken taken
position in defense of freedom of speech
and freedom to read and it's a tradition
that does it honor and should continue
another related question what should the
American Library Association do about
censorship and intellectual repression
in China which is surely as extreme as
in Cuba well it's not quite as extremist
in Cuba probably because the Chinese
have a harder time controlling the
internet but I would say probably the
same thing you should condemn repression
and whatever it's whatever it is I don't
think it's not it's it's it is our
business if we're talking about the
world now that is connected in various
ways and there's certainly a world that
is is is becoming a big village of one
kind or another some like the kind of
village it's becoming others are
proposing another version some people
call it globalization and others call it
global DJ or mobility which is something
different
certainly it's our business the
difference actually was between those
words was made by a French poet who who
didn't like what globalization has come
to mean in economic terms okay proposed
the term global eta is a way of
maintaining the kind of global
connections Karachi is a way of thinking
rather thinking exactly so on and so
forth hey I don't invite you but I I
love French intellectual life I mean it
is so rarefied and I always remember the
story of someone who was called before
some French scientific group and was
asked to demonstrate a machine that had
semi miraculous powers and demonstrate
him to everyone's satisfaction that it
worked and one of the panels said it
obviously works in practice but does it
work in theory
nothing works in theory back to a Cuba
or lass I'm reading these words off a
card I don't agree with them or anything
many pro-castro activists and vocal ala
counselors they imagine the people being
referred to or reject both
characterizations insist that Cuba's
literacy rate is unusually high and that
something did with Robert can't see any
part I can read how would you respond to
that given current political
restrictions and why do you think this
high literacy rate has occurred well
those are the two main propaganda points
of the Cuban regime and also the
now-defunct socialist regimes of Eastern
Europe where the high rate of literacy
and the other was the free the free
medical care both of those things if you
look at them closely are not quite true
to begin with medical care really is
free but it's sort of non-existent I
mean you can yeah you you can get it but
there are no machines or medicines or
well trained people to actually take
care of that and this for literacy yes
people can read but if they don't have
anything to read except state propaganda
what is that it's just a way to me it's
a way to actually create a kind of
illiteracy to destroy whatever
initiative or reason one has for reading
I have two more things on Cuba and I
hope maybe we could move on from that
after this Cuba has school I'm just
reading from the cards Cuba has school
public and a national library with
trained library professionals why have
you chosen not to mention these
professional librarians
but only bring forward Cubans with
personal library collections and I read
the second one well simply because the
Cubans who serve in the State Library
are state employees of the Cuban state
and they're half policemen
they're there to patrol and police the
books rather than to make them available
and a lot of those books are not
available so you know if we're going to
define librarians maybe we should also
talk about you know what percentage of
policemen is in them mm-hmm well I I
think that's true but I'm old enough to
have been active in European libraries
when we had various technical meetings
between various countries and one of the
people that contributed more than almost
anyone else to a particular committee I
was on was an employee of the East
German national library you know a very
fine librarian with lots of technical
skills and so on and so forth
so I think we must recognize that there
are people in situations where they are
professionals they're trying to do
whatever they can it also reminds me of
another story I was asked to speak I
think 25 years ago now to a library
Association meeting in South Africa and
I wrote back I was like younger than and
I wrote back saying I wouldn't go
because they were a segregated Library
Association I didn't want to be
associated with them etcetera etcetera
and I received a heartbreaking letter
back from a librarian in Johannesburg
and africana saying that you know they
are just so cut off that they were
trying to reach out to the wider world
etc etc but I still didn't go and I
always thought that was a kind of a
moral dilemma because I had professional
colleagues under that wicked regime who
were just trying to do their best under
these appalling so composure there were
some clearly there were some in Romania
as well but part of
their work was to to see who could get
access to books and how and so in a way
they were playing the game of the regime
of course even though they personally
despised it its segregated libraries in
this country 40 more years ago and
lastly I hope don't you feel people who
are paid by another country to try to
overthrow the US government with
propaganda materials should be arrested
please check your facts on the Cuba
situation well that's the question
almost doesn't merit an answer it's its
own answer I think it may be a miss
writing and maybe it was overthrow the
Cuban government it says the US
government but anyway yeah I think
people should overthrow all governments
okay I can see the headline Ana kissed
addresses pinko commie librarian
[Applause]
blindsided from way left this is gonna
be televised you know mind that's good
thank God I'm not I'm retiring soon
here's an interesting and different
question do you think the human psyche
will always need the book as it is a
world handheld devices approximating the
size and convenience of the paper book
replace it is there in your opinion
something about the paper book that will
always make it better
well I clearly am a fan of it but I
think it's a historical objects and it's
had a 500 year history and it's going to
probably end in that form originally
people wrote on clay tablets and then on
various kinds of pub bark and other
materials and the printed book had a
history 16th century it's all the 21st
and yes don't be preserved but just as
for you know the actual object I don't
know for a little while there will be
skill morphs is what the architects
called those decorative objects that
remind you of an earlier era for
instance you know Mustang cars are the
horse ornamental times you know you know
I'm in my Bleeker moments I think that
you know it goes against the American
grain which believes in progress and
onward and upward and that each
development is it's an advance but
sometimes I wonder if the past 500 years
were just an aberration in human history
and we had the chaos of the manuscript
age before where manuscripts constantly
were changed and banished for the the
works of authors perish from the earth
you know the libraries were burned down
and all those texts were gone and then
we have this 500 years of a fixity and
authenticity of things being what they
say they are and being preserved and the
baby we're going into a digital age
which is really just
you know the manuscript age only in bits
and bytes where things are not what they
seem where things change things of being
things vanished from the earth they're
not being preserved etc etc may i may be
the last rider my books may be very
valuable because very good but I'm sure
you're right I mean I don't that was a
wonderful sales page by the way his
books may be very valuable when you can
have them for $10 today and also the
younger ones among you can tell your
children that you once sat in a room
with the last writer here's another one
do you remember speaking to the junior
members round table in your lands 20
years ago I called you and invite you to
speak we didn't have very much money so
you did it for I won't mention the Sun
two dollars huh everyone loved you so I
am really responsible for your success
thank you whoever you are
and Robert Newland was kind enough to
sign this thank you Robert yes that make
special thanks Trevor he's absolutely
right
yeah it was I don't remember though
however 20 years is a long time heavens
power it was the number of years I've
been living in New Orleans and there I
think about the city that as you know
that has changed so you've been 20 years
20 20 21 years and you are moving back
well I really ever have an apartment in
New Orleans and I live in Baton Rouge as
well because I teaches Louisiana
stephanie versus if LSU and so what
happened is that all the people from the
Orleans order fleeing their flooded
homes came to Baton Rouge to stay with
me
so some of them are still there
so it's it's the communal life and well
sort of you know 60s commune now but
it's not a voluntary one yeah
and nobody walks around naked because
they're there in the they're not so
young anymore or no but they still wake
up hungry in the middle of the night yes
they look for food now this is one for
me and I'll do it quickly how can we
convince more library schools to
incorporate into their curricula the
wisdom of professionals in the field
second lessons on the effective
efficient use of information resources
from cognitive psychology etc and the
idea that strong libraries are about
people not about machinery and software
I think the answer is with great
difficulty because one of the things
that lis programs are up against are the
brute facts of academic life and
economics in order to do an in-depth
library degree in this age when you need
all these other disciplines as well as
the core you need at least a two-year
course if not more
it needs by its nature expensive and it
is very difficult to see how within the
present structure we could achieve the
kind of all-embracing education which
modern librarians need and my question
or another question I have for you to
think about is how can we overcome those
financial barriers and the barriers
imposed by the strictures of academia to
have a vibrant profession and a stream
of new librarians coming into the
profession that are fully educated
now I have no idea but it would surprise
me if there are many sessions at the
American Medical Association meetings on
a watch of teaching hospitals be
teaching the American Bar Association
what should law schools be teaching the
fact is that you can't graduate from a
teaching hospital without courses and
Anatomy and various other things you
can't graduate from a law school without
courses in constitutional law and other
important things but you can graduate
from an lis program without having taken
a cataloging course and those things are
truly discontinuous and contradictory
and we need to be able to overcome the
obstacles in our path to ensure that our
professional would be professionals
receives the same kind of education at
the same kind of level as would be
doctors and lawyers do we haven't
thanked
thank you my wife told me to smile more
when I was up here but it's very hard
looking into this this blankness to you
know smile of these shifting figures in
the darkness
I'll try are there any more cards any
more questions would anyone like to yell
out a question talk about the book I
think there is a lot of truth and it's a
sad truth which bird Oh his book I saw I
thought you meant to go book okay no
sorry the bird okay is the one they're
gonna talk about a specific book not a
book very good well there is that almost
a wonderful book at the Israel Museum in
in Jerusalem which is a book which is
the scroll that moves around I always
think of that as the book okay in my
book
tell us about your book oh my book yes
oh well it's the book of 20 years of
writings from the city of New Orleans
many of them written in the in the heat
of the extraordinary aura that city has
and it will always have which it really
has almost nothing to do with anything
about it not the buildings or the people
it's just a sort of a deep book a
spirits a locusts genius that lives
there it's there in a book called the
mysteries of New Orleans 1856 by Baron
from the reason Stein a German immigrant
to the new world who wrote a serial in
the German language a newspaper in New
Orleans and it was filled with the kind
of magic of the place that is still
there so how he got onto it and how
writers and artists get onto that I
don't know it's a mysterious channel so
hopefully the book is about those things
did you go back to these essays and as
politicians say revise and extend your
remarks
oh did you just publish them as they
were first part of the many of them at
the end of the book are after Katrina so
they're really considerations of the
city after the storm but the one certain
before no I wouldn't dare to do that I
mean I barely dared to read them when I
was copy editing them I think that would
be a I'm against revision of that kind
certainly they do there's a Romanian
writer I mentioned before militarily are
they who wrote to nows cereals in
newspapers and when they were published
his books he hadn't read them until they
were books and he was astounded at how
coherent they were okay so I'm just
hoping that the same thing pertains
Somerset Maugham had a very effective
stammer which he deployed to great
effect and he was once asked about some
detail in one of his books and he said
oh dear boy you have the other Vantage
of me
you've obviously reread my books and I
never have okay here's one is there
historical record of the importance and
role of libraries in changing despotic
governments or is the evidence assumed
from the other is the evidence arrived
out from censorship it seems that
America is approved to the contrary in
spite of a wealth of information and
encouraged access the public seems to
favor ignorance just providing books
does not make people make people read or
think it's an excellent point but the
books were essential to but they are
essential to repressive regimes the the
whole idea of revolution began in the
dank basement of the print shop the
pamphlets and
the radical literature that eventually
ended up unsettling societies came from
printers and and and the early the the
technology of the book and so naturally
I mean the reason why those regimes in
Eastern Europe and in the Soviet Union
lasted as long as as as they did is
because they they had an almost awesome
sacred fear of the book and so they
certainly learnt it a great deal of of
the of the aura of mystery that books
have but on the other hand it was the
books themselves it was absolutely maybe
their fear of them and it was harder in
the fact that they were forbidden made
that more desirable but I don't think
that's the chief reason why books
contributed to the overthrow or of those
regimes or the end of the police states
in in Eastern Europe and in Russia
this is rendre you were interviewed in
The New York Times Sunday magazine about
the aftermath of Katrina your opinion
was that New Orleans has had its days
and that the rebuilding of the city will
result in a theme-park
of fo New Orleans without the grit and
charm pre Katrina have events over the
past few months changed this opinion
well let's see what's today Sunday I'm
an optimist
tomorrow I will not be no the events are
changing constantly right now there are
two plants before New Orleanians and
before the country and one of them calls
for a smaller City a business a more
businesslike City and more efficient
City a more American city now New
Orleans has never quite had been an
American city and I don't think America
really likes New Orleans or like New
Orleans because its first of all the
French built it then then it has all
those qualities that we don't appreciate
anymore
things like laissez faire and leisure
and lassitude Chinese in Indonesian yes
had the hedonism and things like that
those are not efficient things they
don't make make us earn money and move
forward so there is something about New
Orleans that is poetic that is this idea
of culture now it's very hard to define
culture and to say well what is this
culture the culture that everybody
thinks of as the New Orleans culture is
really a culture that came from poverty
it came from misery the question now is
do we somehow replicate conditions of
poverty and misery in order to have this
so-called think home so-called culture
or do we make an effort to actually make
people's lives better which is really
the more important thing in my mind so
culture whatever that is this is
important and it's still there but it is
it is rather vaporators at this point
not hard to define I remember reading
once that the best thing that ever
happened to Chicago was the Chicago Fire
that it would not be the city it was if
they'd had to build around the existing
buildings and so on yeah well I'm going
to wait a hundred years before I make
that judgment the American Library
Association never forgets you will be
ours maybe you'd like to comment on this
I find your remark about criminals
leaving New Orleans and now practicing
their craft in Houston and other places
offensive this is not the Tonight Show
and you are not Jay Leno right I think
we grasp that point 99% of the evacuees
are law-abiding citizens also it's bad
taste to make fun of the situation so
Houston's expanse well there's only 1%
actually of the people I mean they're
only 1% of our criminals in any case so
of course 99% are in the sad situation
you know but the fact is that a lot of
bad guys want different places and
Houston's crime rate spiked you can look
it up and they blame quite a few of our
refugees you don't I mean that's just
the facts this is a similar comment
aimed at me
how do you feel about the discrimination
and repression practiced by quotes
radical liberal librarians against those
in the profession who are more
conservative ideologically and
politically well it's very mad about it
how do you feel I feel terrible
yeah it's really
[Applause]
it's keeping me awake nights too it's
like Hollywood suppression of the people
I have just a couple of things about
library education and these times when
libraries have to compete for their
dollars they desperately need essential
business skills how can these be
incorporated in library school I think
that is so true that we do not teach
enough management and by that I mean
humane management not the ghastly
management speak you find in most you
know books on management I mean the very
worst library administrator I ever knew
never read anything but management
textbooks so I think the there is a
place for humane management and the use
of business skills to achieve good ends
but I don't think that the culture of
libraries science programs would ever
admit the kind of social Darwinism which
a lot of business schools go in for
another one
why don't I include library students in
my discussions in the program yesterday
I think there was Friday there were no
students on the panel it's not their
perspective valuable it's certainly
different from those of faculty this was
a conscious choice on my part because I
attended about 18 months ago a panel a
day long program afternoon long program
on library education in the New York
area and all the deans of all the
schools in the greater area were there
and there was one panel of students all
of whom said what a wonderful time they
were having in in the programs and how
much they enjoyed it and what great
value for their money they were getting
and how they were looking forward to
getting a degree from this prestigious
institution then they had a panel of
students who'd left library schools
graduated two or three years before they
were almost uniformly negative so I I
came to the conclusion
that it is very difficult for a current
student to really speak their minds in
this kind of forum and I didn't want to
put anyone in that kind of position but
I certainly have been talking to a lot
of student groups and student chapters
and getting informal responses to my
initiative from them I guess this could
be a last one but we happy to take any
more I can't find the car but I remember
what it said oh here it is so Michael
and Andre what are you currently reading
well I'm currently reading all the
novels of Michael Harrington that I can
find he wrote the architecture of the
Arkansas Ozarks among others novel
called with because I have a great
interest now in the Arkansas Ozarks and
his novels I find marvelous I think he's
our great magical realist like Marquez
Michael Harrington and one are yes his
book Michael Harrington who was once
described as America's foremost
socialist the man you know not the same
person this is Harrington Edwin R and
he's he lives in Fair developes of men
in his I think his seventies and he's
just a marvelous writer in his books are
out of print artifact yeah
thank you very much the other Michael
has other terms as I say was described
as America's foremost socialist and
William Buckley who combines loathsome
opinions with a quick with said that
that being described as America's
foremost foremost socialist is like
being the tallest building in Topeka
Kansas
I just finished a wonderful book by an
English writer called Frances Wien wh
een who by the way and here I'm
cementing the reputation of myself and
the association was a wonderful
biography of Karl Marx Pinker librarian
praises commie author Michael
Harrington's he had a live with Armand
Frances Wayne wrote a book which was
published in Britain as how mumbo jumbo
conquered the world and it's been
published in this country as idiot-proof
and I thoroughly recommend it to anybody
who's worried about the tide of
irrationalism and fundamentalism and all
the kind of craziness that there is in
the culture Spain any other comments
capitals criticisms well thank you Andre
this has been a wonderful